pft props uh per points bet the new
official sports betting partner of nbc
sports who has more passing yards
tonight
joe burrow of the bengals or baker
mayfield of the browns chris
i'm gonna go joe burrow here i don't i
guess what i i think that baker mayfield
and company are going to be able to run
the football and dominate the line of
scrimmage that's why i'm saying this
the bangles have a pretty good secondary
um
so i think that the browns will really
focus on the run game and take advantage
of that tonight and i also
i think i expect the browns to be
winning in this football game
the bangles offensive line not that
great i don't see them running the ball
all that effectively on this browns d
line which is pretty good
and i think burrell will probably have
to throw the ball against the beat up
secondary in cleveland too and he's got
some weapons i'm going to go with joe
burrow
yeah i'm going to agree with you on that
again after watching that game last
night the borough
debut there's magic there there's
there's there's some
some some stuff that makes you scratch
your head no doubt if he can iron that
out there's still plenty of stuff that's
natural and
effortless and i think that he's going
to be
a very very good quarterback if he can
harness himself and point himself in the
right direction learn from his mistakes
but i think he'll have more yards
tonight
uh even though i i well you know what he
should have more yards because baker
mayfield should have a hundred or fewer
because they should just run the ball
repeatedly with nick chubb and kareem
hunt if they want to win tonight
they're gonna run the ball run the ball
run the ball because the ravens couldn't
stop the run
yeah and for whatever reason the browns
decided well we just won't run
even though they're not stopping the run
all right
well either guy will either guy get to
300 it was borough with 193 and mayfield
with 189 in week one does either guy get
to 300.
uh i don't think so
i i feel like it'll be like a high 280
maybe
burrow if he gets there i mean i mean
maybe uh i think the game would have to
unfold he probably needs one real big
pass play but
like i said i think burrell will end up
with the more passing yards and i think
he'll four
with 300 i'm gonna say he falls just
short of it
uh i i agree neither guy is going to get
to 300 tonight i mean neither guy got to
200
last week and it's a short week and it's
a lot of work to do and
you know they got joe mixon in
cincinnati too and that leads to the
next one who has more rushing yards
nick chubb or joe mixon mixon had 69
yards on 19 carries that's a 3.6 yards
per attempt
and and also he had an ugly fumble his
first fumble since his rookie season
he got hit ball flies out it killed a
drive for the bengals uh who's got more
rushing yards mixing her chub
i'm gonna go chub here all the way i am
i mean again i i that bra
like we've we've talked about the browns
oh line they can move some people
in the run game and i no gino atkins
with the cincinnati bengals
i just look at that advantage cleveland
and the cincinnati bengals offensive
line it's still
a work in progress that way and the
browns d-line
you could say what you want about it
it's real it's the real deal
you know they weren't over matched and
pushed around last week against
baltimore whom we know they can do it
they they were okay to hang in there
that wasn't really the issue of the
football game
but man miles garrett olivier vernon
ogun joby
sheldon richardson that front four yeah
i don't think you're going to be able to
get 100 yards on that group tonight hey
ogun joby just appeared in the backfield
a lot right early in that game yeah i
mean he was
look that and again 38 to six oh they
got blown out oh they stink oh and look
there is some disfunction that
dysfunction there is some disarray in
cleveland right now but they didn't get
blown out now it's their own fault
that it ended up 38-6 it's their own
fault that they didn't capitalize on
opportunities to keep the game close
or or or have a chance to win it because
they didn't
stay committed to the run but they did
not get blown off the field they didn't
get embarrassed if anything they
embarrassed themselves in not doing the
things needed to be done
to make the game more competitive all
right more receiving yards aj green
or obj i'm going to go aj green i mean i
got to see it
that baker and obj can connect and as we
talked about and you you brought it up
with you know jesse bates who's a
heat-seeking missile
and william jackson i would think is
going to be matched up on odell beckham
jr i'm telling you that's going to be
fun to watch tonight i i really
encourage people to watch it this 22
can really cover and odell as we know he
looked healthy as hell to me
aj green looked healthy too and i think
that joe burrow
understands how important he is he's
going to be his go-to guy
they missed they were this close on a
few other big plays
i'm going to go aj five catches for 51
yards for aj green
last week 3 for 22 for beckham he was
targeted
10 times in the game and only had three
catches so i'm going to go aj green also
i
i think that that here's the reality the
browns still have not
lost that mentality from last year that
we must get the ball to odell beckham jr
we must get the ball to odell beckham jr
so you take away obj
and you frustrate him you frustrate
baker mayfield
you frustrate the offense so you know
either way whether they commit to the
run and forget about the pass and only
pass when absolutely necessary
or they try to pass and they try to
force it to odor beckham jr they get
frustrated
either way i think aj green is going to
have more more yardage i am astounded
one of the big things i thought in
moving on from freddie kitchens they
would get away from this
obsession with forcing the ball to odell
beckham jr with getting the ball in his
hands x
number of times and and we've already
seen that that there is that
undercurrent and that undercurrent is
going to be there
for as long as they expect mayfield and
beckham to coexist because
deep down i don't think they want to
chris yeah i mean
it it i maybe you're right mike gosh i
don't know
i'm just i'm shocked that it hasn't
worked out yet
it's unbelievable to see two guys as
talented as they are and really not
connect and just have not found any
rhythm or chemistry with each other
um i don't know where it goes but yeah
i'm not picking odell to
outpace aj green right now with the way
that connections looked or lack of
connection
we have one more prop and it doesn't
come from points but it comes from our
producer pete demelitis
missed field goal extra point combined
for cody parkey and randy bullock
over under 2.5 chris let's see
we had what did we have last week
cincinnati just missed the one x
the one field all right and cody parkey
did he miss he missed a field goal and
an extra point right so it was
three total last week if i'm if i'm
remembering that correctly
austin oh that's right last week and
then he got cut
i forgot right sorry okay i'm gonna go
the under
i think we see two i think we're gonna
see one or two but i don't know i just
can't pick three i'm not gonna put the
the bad juju on these guys they'll miss
an extra point and somebody will miss
one field goal
i'm going the ender for a very simple
reason i don't think randy bullock's
gonna kick tonight
the browns cut austin cyber the bengals
trade i claimed him on waivers they've
got two kickers on the roster
randy randy bullock after he missed that
that field goal that would have sent the
game to overtime he grabbed both
legs and he's been on the injury report
all week with cavs not
calf so it's the double rodney
dangerfield oh my arm it's broken
although he apparently did get himself
injured when he kicked that field goal
and uh i don't think he's going to kick
so if he doesn't kick he isn't going to
miss any kicks so i'm going to go under
because i think it's
just gonna be uh austin cyber ending up
getting the nod for the bengals tonight
but uh
but who knows it would be fitting if
austin cyber four days after right that
would be good
for the browns comes in and kicks the
game-winning field goal for the
cincinnati bengals to take down
you know you're jinxed if you lose that
way cleveland i don't know what else to
say
i i look i i they got to do something i
i think it's it's critical
you know it's way too early to say this
is a must-win game but when you consider
the broader history of the bengal or the
browns rather and where they are and
what's expected of them
there's going to be fans there tonight a
certain number are allowed to attend i
i think they really need to win this
game they can't afford to fall to owen
two
uh they they and if they do then you
really do have to force yourself back to
square one as an organization and make
tough decisions tougher than getting rid
of a kicker
about what you're doing at quarterback
what you're doing with obj what your
philosophy is
because if the runs there tonight and
they abandon it again i i
i'm not going to know what to say
because look
if you and i can spot it they surely in
looking at the film realized
we should have stuck to the run here and
we'll see if they do it tonight
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports